This is,
the final day for the Knowles
Connections conference
brought to you,
by Connected Data London and
the knowledge graph,
conference.
This is our second
track, innovators,
and, have the great
pleasure of
welcoming, here today,
Sebastian Schmidt,
who's the co CEO
of MetaFacts.
Co CEO is actually
not very familiar,
title, not one
many people have.
Sebastian does.
And he's here today
to talk to us about,
how knowledge graphs,
can power FAIR,
platform. And by FAIR, well,
it's an acronym you may be or
not be familiar with.
Sebastian will explain it.
I'll give the floor to him.
Thanks a lot, George.
So also welcome
from from me on
the presentation on your game
plan for building a knowledge
graph to a fair
data platform.
So, a few words on myself.
My name is Sebastian Schmidt.
As as George mentioned,
I'm co CEO at MatterFacts.
So I'm, running the company
together with Peter Hasso,
who founded it in two
thousand fourteen.
I actually come from
a cloud and and,
infrastructure background,
but I've always been a big fan
of knowledge graphs.
And, I'm happy for being about
one and a half years
part of a truly
digital business and working
with a lot of knowledge
graph experts.
Keep people behind,
for example,
the the owl draft
or also pushing
on on new topics like,
RDF style and sparkle style.
So, who is MetaFacts?
As I said, we
started out in two
thousand fourteen.
We are based out of
Waldorf, Germany,
and, we have an international
team really across multiple
locations from
Australia, Germany,
Russia, Ireland,
all over the globe.
We have one product which is
Meta Factory, our knowledge
graph platform And we
use that product,
to drive
digital transformation
with our customers.
And that's
specifically around,
unlocking the value
of the data
assets using knowledge graphs
as the underlying
technology stack.
And what I want
to present today
is an approach,
we have implemented
with a number
of customers in in
different verticals.
So we are working
with customers
in in cultural heritage and
digital humanities
and engineering,
manufacturing,
finance, insurance,
pharma, and and life science.
And we have built knowledge
graph based
applications and and
tools from,
a bit of material
management to
a digital museum,
solutions like for for drug
discovery and and
drug repurposing.
So, really a lot of different
domains where we
bring in the the
expertise of how do you build
a knowledge graph and,
how can you do
that really fast.
And our customers
bring in their
specific domain expertise.
So, what is it about digital
transformation?
Where do we see
this demand coming from for
building such
knowledge graphs?
We see that
a number of drivers
are behind why companies wanna
establish
a digital transformation
strategy from,
really just enabling
innovation,
bringing new products
to the market,
driving additional business,
to increasing
engagement with,
the employees,
internal customers,
partners, to improving
operations.
So, very often,
it's also just
an an internally
focused effort to
make sure that
internal processes once mover
access to relevant information
is available at the time it's
needed and, is complete
and is reliable.
When talking about how to get
to digital transformation,
this is something
you might have
seen before. So there's this
approach of, first
talk to people,
talk to your customers,
talk to your partners,
talk to your employees,
and understand the gaps
and the needs.
Then it is finding
the right data,
using the data
in the right way
to drive digital processes and
with those, digital processes
to support them with
digital tools.
The approach we are taking on
that is is a truly
agile approach,
and I'm gonna, highlight that
a few times throughout
the presentation.
So it's all about
planning, building,
testing those
individual steps and,
iterations on each of those
steps as needed.
So wherever we are
in that process,
the idea is you
can at any time
go back to
the previous steps,
fill gaps that you
identified later on,
retest new hypothesis,
and and make sure that you are
actually achieving
the the goal
that you have set out.
And it might even be adjusting
that goal, as you
are going along.
This is a lot of
ground to cover.
So today I'm gonna
focus really,
purely on the the data
aspect of this.
So how do we build FAIR data?
FAIR data that stands
for findable,
accessible, interoperable,
and reusable data.
And I will highlight three of
the key steps we see which is
describing your data,
modeling your data,
and then using your data.
As mentioned,
we are using the semantic web
knowledge graph standard for
that to derive knowledge from
this data and to also further
drive prediction
with artificial
intelligence and
machine learning.
So when we talk about data and
digital transformation,
most of our projects actually
start from the point
of looking
at what kind of
data is available.
And I think there's
no enterprise
that has a lack of available
data but the challenge
is usually about,
what can I actually
do with this data?
Is this relevant data for what
I wanna achieve here?
Who created it?
So who can I reach
out to to get
more detail about it?
Which processing
steps have been
applied to this data?
Is this, in some
way modified?
How do I interpret
that correctly?
Is that, reliable data?
So do I have
contradicting data
available or other
data that is,
supporting the information I
would derive from it?
Where and when
was it created?
So is it still relevant?
And what was
the intended use?
So with what, idea was it
initially created
and and that's
that properly applied to,
what I'm planning
to do with it.
And there are a number of
approaches we see that our
customers have taken to answer
those questions
and get a better
understanding of their data.
The most successful
approach at
describing your
data is is really
taking all of your data,
all of those digital assets in
the same way. Meaning,
that could be any
kind of private
data or public
data that is not
yet cataloged, that is just
existing in in
some way in your
enterprise, or
existing catalog
solutions you
might have already
established, which
we very often
see are building
on proprietary
standards, are
building mostly,
as a siloed solution.
So, most customers I'm working
with have actually
two or three
catalog solutions in place.
None of them covering,
let's say,
a very significant
part of the data.
It's it's usually in the range
of twenty, maybe
thirty percent.
And the idea is bringing in
documentation provenance
and lineage.
And what we are proposing for
that is is building on those w
three c standards.
So building on the RDF data
formats to build
a semantic data
catalog and using,
vocabularies from
from DCAD and
BRAVO to,
on the one side
with DCAD model
really What kind
of data that is,
where it comes from,
and and how you can reach out
to get more
information about it,
how you can get to the actual
source of that
data and combining
that with Provo to understand
the kind of transformations
modifications that
have happened
to the data and,
what happened before this data
actually reached,
the the system where you are
interacting with it now.
So to make it a little
bit more visual,
I have a demo.
I have a fallback
version as a video,
but let's try if we can maybe
have the actual demo system.
So this is our, meta
factory tool and,
we have a number of asset
management interfaces
built in here.
And I wanna start
out from the data
cataloging interface here.
So what we can see is all of
those different
properties defined
in in DCAD to filter
the available
datasets we have
in the system.
We, for example,
can look at the link
Nobel Prize
dataset here. We
can, look at that.
And what we are doing
is we we populate,
a page in, some
kind of a linked
data browser kind of concept.
So we are now on the on that
individual dataset.
We get information
about this dataset.
We can see the URI
and the type
of this dataset we have here.
It is possible to
modify the dataset.
And all of
those configurations
are directly loaded
from the DCAD model.
The model that's defined with
that DCAD standard,
that open standard is directly
driving the user
interface and,
how information is presented.
From here, I can also explore
the graph that's behind it.
So I can, for example,
see all of the incoming and
outgoing links for
this data set.
I can see the the publisher.
I can also look
into the the model
information of type data set.
I can see there are number of
other resources
that are of that
same type.
So we can take one of those in
as well and and see
the the different
kind of datasets
we have in our
knowledge graph and really
navigate from one resource to
the other and and get a better
understanding. We have,
auto populating
knowledge panels
that show you
context information
about everything
in that knowledge
graph. And through that,
you can really browse your
datasets and build a central
system driven by
an open standard
by an open data
model where you
can learn about
all the different
datasets that are available to
you and that you are working
within your company.
Now the next step is
modeling your data.
So now that we actually have
information about where this
data comes from,
what kind of data
that is, and,
where we get to to
more information
about it, it is very important
to put a model on.
And I'm not talking
about a classical
relational database model or
something like that.
So this is not to
describe the structure
, the data types of my data,
but this is about
describing my
domain model.
Because it's very
important if you wanna be
effective in using the data at
hand that you describe,
what kind of data it actually
is and how
the different concepts
and relations are interacting
in your specific dataset.
So what we are seeing here is
a case from from pharma domain
where we have a number of data
sources in our
data catalog and
we are showing here how those
public available data sources
actually interlink
on a on a higher
level, model.
So we see that we
have genes and
and proteins and
and transcripts
which are all,
subclasses of
biomolecular entities.
And we see how
a protein connects
to a pathway.
So without actually being in
the pharma domain,
I can get
a basic understanding
of of what kind of things are
modeled in this data.
What kind of information I can
extract from that.
And that's the idea
of this approach.
We are using, the OWL and and
Shackle standards for that.
So so most of what
you're seeing
here is actually
modeled through OWL,
But we see that,
you also wanna
model things like
constraints. So you
might wanna define,
this relationship between gene
and protein. So this encodes
relationship we have here.
How many,
proteins can be
encoded by a gene.
And to define that,
OLL doesn't give you
any way to do that.
So that's why we are combining
it with Shackle
to allow you to
model those
constraints as well.
So, again, how
does that work?
So from the the perspective of
metafactory, that's
just another asset.
So, in this case,
we're looking at
an ontology asset.
You can also see
that we have,
an integration with
with git here.
So those are all not versioned
in git right now but we have
again the Nobel
Prize dataset here.
We see this is
versioned in git
with no active
changes on this.
And we can go
into that now and
we can really modify
our model here.
So what we see are, again,
the the core concepts
of this dataset.
We are seeing,
those constraints
like there's an exact
one relation
between a word file
and a file type.
And one common step you would
wanna do is,
after you have actually built
the ontology, which
you can do in here,
so you can can modify parts of
the ontology. You
can add relations.
You can add
additional classes.
But you can also tie it into,
other ontologies.
So we see a lot of customers
building kind of a more higher
level ontology where all of
the specific domain ontologies
can tie into.
And that's also
why you're seeing
such a lot of
classes in here.
So if you, for example,
would only look at the local
ontology you can see it's it's
a lot less here.
So let me quickly jump back to
to all ontologies and,
pick out something
that does not
come from this ontology itself
but comes from
another ontology.
So for example,
we pick out
the the agent and,
the document.
We can see that for them,
there are already
relations defined.
And now we can go here and say
that an award file and take
the subclass
relation is actually
a subclass of a document.
Lawyer is actually a subclass
of an agent.
And now we can
save this change.
And we can also now
do validation.
So we can actually
see how much
of our data is conformed
to this model.
So if I'm going back
to my, ontologies,
I can do a validation
step here
and we should now get a new
entry here for new
data quality report.
And we can see that,
with our latest report,
we have a few
elements which are
not conformant,
with our model.
So we can right
away go in here
and we can learn
that the minimum
cardinality for for file type
and for year is not,
correctly set for
some of those
elements. And we can now learn
also which specific note does
not provide it.
So for example,
here we see the device file.
And that leads
back again to our
linked data browser.
So the idea is really that
everything is in
the knowledge graph.
The catalog is in
The model is in
the knowledge graph.
And also the data validation
information is part of that
knowledge graph.
And everything is interlinked
and can be accessed
from every point,
of where you are
in your dataset.
The deontology
or your schema,
your model, that's one piece.
The other one is,
bringing that together
with a controlled
vocabulary. We are
using SCOS for that.
So you see an example where we
are modeling,
the the controlled vocabulary
for diseases in this case.
And then,
we have built that system so
that you have interfaces for
specific user types.
So we are seeing more and more
customers adopting
the the ideas
of a semantic modeler being
responsible for that overall
modeling process,
kind of the the gatekeeper
to the model.
Domain experts actively
participating in
modeling as well as,
building out the vocabularies
and data stewards
that have some,
interaction with those those
models or ontologies,
but are mostly active around
building the data catalog,
bringing the data
into the system,
mapping it into models
and vocabularies,
and making it available.
To support that process,
and and I don't
really have time
to talk about that a lot,
but we have also implemented
the W3C reconciliation service
API draft.
So you can use that to
have a standardized
interface to look up what is
the idea the the IP
for one of my,
resources or entities.
So every new dataset and all
the new data you are bringing
into your knowledge graph will
correctly map into what's
available already.
So the third and final step is
using your data.
And that's interestingly one
that's often overlooked when
knowledge graphs are built in
the beginning. And
that has been,
one of our focus
points all along.
So we, together with
our customers,
built, wireframes.
So really discussing
the the requirements
from from data, people,
processes for
the user experience.
And then take that
into Meta Factory,
which is also,
a model driven
local platform.
So that that linked
data browser
you saw as well as
all the interfaces,
they are highly customizable
which means they are
just HTML pages,
that are connected to a number
of of templates
where we use our,
predefined and graph enabled
components to put those
visualizations and
interfaces together.
And everything that you would
like to have in
a different way
you can modify.
This all sits on
top of a graph
database where
the data is stored.
And all of the configuration
like you saw it
for the model,
but also for those template
pages is stored in
a versioning system.
Which makes ultimately
the the platform
itself a stateless component
that's just putting the things
together and creating
the interface
to interact with it.
Or in the same way providing
that through APIs to a larger
ecosystem of analytics
prediction,
AI, ML solutions.
We do have a public
demo system
based on Wikidata.
And, if you if you open that
system on wikidata.
Matter of fact dot com,
there's an example gallery of
some of the components
we provide.
And I just wanna show you,
two examples quickly.
So there is one option here to
combine a keyword search with
a a tree visualization.
So we are seeing
the, the tree of,
diseases here and and how that
that connects in this taxonomy
called MeSH.
And here we can look behind
the cover of how this
is actually built.
So what you see is it is our
tree component.
It has a query to find,
parents and it has a query to
do the the keyword lookup.
And interestingly,
you can also see that we are
also federating
here over a number
of repositories combining mesh
with Wikidata. So these few
lines give you that
user interface,
that you're seeing here where
you can freely interact
with this data.
Which means if you are,
able to write
a sparkle query,
you are actually able to write
a front end interface
in meta factory.
And if you are
not able to write
a sparkle query,
we have an interactive
query builder.
So you can actually say I'm
looking for a person connected
to an organization,
where that organization
is the employer,
and where that organization is
related to a place,
which is the headquarter
location.
And that might be London.
And now we select
the London we
are interested in.
And now we get
a result and and
we can extract
the sparkle query
from it. We can
also combine it
with and and or
clauses and make
it obviously a lot
more complex query.
But through that,
I can derive my results that I
can derive,
an actual spark agreement that
I can use then in those
visualizations or I can even
provide that as
a query builder
to my end users
to interact with
the dataset.
So we have built a number of
systems as I said.
It's probably
around one hundred
applications we
have built before
our customers in
the last years.
Just some few examples here.
And, as I mentioned
it before,
all of this is following this
agile approach.
So, that's also
true for all of
those assets,
datasets, mappings,
ontologies,
vocabularies as well
as the the UI templates.
For all of them,
we are following
an agile approach
with versioning in in Git and
relevant governance
processes around it.
And the idea is that
with that approach,
you can really go from a proof
of concept,
in just one to two
weeks to an an MVP,
and a production
system in a month
or even less. So we have
successfully implemented that
for for some use cases in in
just two weeks,
getting something
to the end user,
being able to iterate
in weekly sprints,
getting feedback in getting
additional data sources in
expanding the model,
expanding the vocabulary
and so on.
So, yeah. With that,
I think I'm at
the end of the the
twenty five minutes.
That that was the end
of the twenty
five minutes,
and that was also
me muting. What I wanted to do
was actually
enable my screen,
Sebastian, for for setting up
your your screen.
At least it it happened after
you had finished
your your talk.
So, it's a good time to open
the floor to questions,
and we already have
one, actually.
We've had that
almost since the,
the beginning of your talk.
It's, one from Dean Aleman.
It's a very specific one.
So if, Dean will
allow me, I will,
broaden in the the scope
a little bit.
So, Dean's question is,
if someone's already using
Collibra for their
data catalog,
is there an easy
way to migrate
that into a knowledge
graph like
the one, you showed
in your slides?
I would expand
the scope a little
bit because,
the question, excuse me,
the question is specifically
about one data
catalog, solution.
There are there are
many in the market.
So while it's
generalized, like,
is there a way
for someone who's
using some whatever other data
catalog solution to
to to transition,
let's say, to what
you're using.
So we we are seeing
that specifically,
specific one quite
a lot, actually.
So I would say it's,
it's part of,
like, eighty percent
of the solutions
we have built around,
data cataloging.
And we are not yet where we
wanna be with that.
So, as we, for example,
have also
enhanced capabilities
around the the visual ontology
building just with the last
release to the the point that
you saw just now.
We are also looking
into how we
can make that, onboarding of
existing catalogs smoother and
and easier. Right now there's
there's some manual process
still involved with that,
but we we see that,
over the I would
say next year,
this becomes
a highly automated
process to to speed
up those projects,
even further. Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
We also have, again,
a rather specific
question from
from Daniel. I don't know if
it's one you can answer,
but I'm gonna pass
it on anyway.
He asked about
pricing and whether
we provide licenses
for research
purposes. Yes.
So we,
we are ourselves
very active in
research. So we also
wanna support,
research. And and therefore,
if you are interested
in an academic
license or something
like that,
reach out. We have,
under matter of fact dot com
slash get started.
We have a a public
trial that's
accessible to to everyone.
You can run this in the cloud
or on premises.
And, if you have a research
academic need, just
put that into the,
the comment field or reach out
via email and we'll give you,
directly access,
to that. Okay.
Actually, I also
have a question
for you, because
at some point,
you mentioned the agile
approach and,
iteration and versioning,
but it's for data.
And this is
something that I see
coming up actually
a lot, increasingly,
I would say, beyond
the the confines
of data cataloging
or knowledge
perhaps or what have you,
it's something that's that's
that's there is a need for,
and it's getting
more widespread.
So even for people
doing machine
learning or any dealing with
with data and data science in
any other capacity,
let's say.
Because people are realizing
it's a bit like code.
So you do have iteration.
So your data set will change.
Your data set will
evolve over time.
So you need a way
to keep track
of that and different versions
and which version everyone has
and all of that.
So how do you
approach and resolve
this issue in your platform?
So for for UI templates,
for ontologies,
for vocabularies,
it's fairly straightforward
because the the amount of data
is usually quite controllable
and and the approach
with using
a versioning system
like git for
that is what's
implemented most
of the time. For data,
it becomes a little bit more
tricky because
sometimes that's
just not the approach that's
that's relevant or
interesting there.
So we have a number
of ways how
we can do
the the versioning there.
We are, for example,
working with,
different, named graphs.
So depending on the technology
that's underneath
in the database
available to provide
kind of a staging
area for datasets,
or other approaches around
maintaining specific
user changes.
So we also have
the the capabilities
of providing those forms and
every change is then tracked
with provenance
information from
the user and versioning
information.
So you can actually play back
all the changes
that that users
have entered entered
into the system.
And in the same way,
you can also do that for for
other ways how data might get
into that system.
So for for data,
it's still a little
custom based
on the specific need.
I think there's there's no one
way to do it right,
but we have,
implemented that
from just small
scale to to large
scale changes.
And we we have
approaches to to
help with that. Okay. Yeah.
I think the, the named graph
solution that you mentioned
makes makes sense.
But as you also pointed out,
there is can currently,
to the best of my knowledge,
at least not
the standardized way to,
to move between
different name graphs.
So I guess you have to somehow
add some proprietary
elements to that.
It's it's actually we're not
really applying
a proprietary element,
other than, you know,
maybe a kind of a an extension
to the vocabulary that we
specifically use for that.
It still stays RDF.
It still stays, open
and standardized.
And what we can, for example,
also employ for that is is LDP
containers. So that's that's
another technical
approach, to help us,
enable that. Okay.
Okay. Yeah.
I was just
specifically interested
in that because,
yeah, as I said,
and you also
mentioned it's it's
an issue, that many and many
more organizations
are facing.
So I was just curious how you
deal with it. Okay.
So what yeah.
We'll we'll have
to be wrapping
up so that, people
can move on to,
the next session.
Thanks, everyone. Bye. Bye.